hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another video today I want to talk about
another one of my favorite tools that
are used to run my business and it's
called buffer and I use it to manage my
Twitter account now when I first started
using Twitter I got a little frustrated
in that I don't want to be on Twitter
all day long and I wanted to be able to
share the content that I wanted to tweet
about over a period of time so I didn't
want to have 10 tweets go out all at
once and kind of bombard all my
followers and then have nothing for the
next 24 hours so a solution that I found
for this was called buffer and I'll give
you a quick tour about how it works and
hopefully how you can use of yours your
your business as well so this is my
favorite tools page and just go find
buffer and we'll click on it to load it
up so this is buffer and what buffer
basically allows you to do is set times
for when you want to send out your
tweets so I used another tool a free
tool called crowd booster which maybe
I'll talk about a different video but
what that does is basically tell you
what time people are looking at your
tweets so it helps you optimize when you
send out your tweets so you might be you
know really good at working late at
night and that's when you find all your
best stuff but maybe your readers are
reading it mostly during the afternoon
so you can schedule to go out at the
times that work best for you so
according to the crowd booster analytics
the best times for me are two o'clock
three o'clock 11 o'clock in the
afternoon and then seven eight and nine
o'clock in the morning so what I've done
with my buffer is set up all of my
tweets to go out we'll add those times
so you can see here that I have 5 tweets
that are scheduled to come out and right
now these are different articles that I
want to highlight so they're coming out
of 23 11 7 8 and if I had another one
benign and it just goes out
automatically it's synced with my
Twitter account and add those times it's
going to automatically go out to my
audience now the great way to use buffer
is if I find an article that I want to
promote so here's an example of one that
I wanted to tweet out it's called death
by sitting I use a stand-up desk
something I've talked about before so
I like reading about stuff that supports
my cause hear about standing up so this
is an article it talks about sitting
down and how it can really harm you so I
have a button up here that's in my
chrome called buffer for chrome and it's
an extension and if I click on it it'll
load up the buffer and what this does is
pull the title of the article and it
shortens the link and if i add it to my
buffer it'll automatically go and we put
in for the rest of my schedule i can
change the text to whatever i want and i
can also post it right now if i wanted
to go it immediately instead of waiting
for it to go at a different time so for
me I can either use this button here or
there's a shortcut that I recently
learned if you type all be the same
thing happens so if you don't want to
put the browser and you just do all
being the same thing loads up so I can
either just use the article title here
or another thing i could do is if I
really like a sentence in the article
you know I could highlight the sentence
here and click buffer and what it does
here is use that sentence as my tweet so
let's give me my tweet that goes out
tells me I have five characters left be
able to use or can also just type
whatever message I want so I could put
in you know still happy with my stand-up
desk for example and I can click add the
buffer and you can see now that if i
refresh my dashboard I have six tweets
and that one scheduled to come out at
nine o'clock tomorrow
so I really like that it's an easy way
to add to my Twitter of a constant
stream of things going out to my Twitter
account at optimal times and I'm not
having to worry about always being
online at those times opposed to myself
another cool thing you can do so this is
if you have articles that you want to
send out you can also retweet articles
so if I load up am i loading a maria's
account here works with me and if I
wanted to retweet something that she
posted for example I could click on one
of her articles here so she posted
article today setting goals to achieve
right here this little buffer button
that I can click on that and retweet it
from here or i can actually cook on the
tweet itself i can see a little buffer
icon here as well i click on that buffer
and the same thing happens so it says
retweet the count again i can enter in
my own message if i want and whenever
I'm ready add the buffer and so now
that's been added and if i refresh here
you see that that's going to be set it
for two o'clock the next day so I really
find this useful system helps me manage
my Twitter account way more effective in
from was doing it manually so how to
update those settings that's kind of how
to add articles to buffer if I want to
update the time that it goes out and
click on my settings and I can pick the
times that I want to go out so I've set
it up for seven eight nine to three and
11 those were the times again that were
the highest impact for me but you can
add a new time you can modify these
times whatever you want to do basically
you can update your own time zone you
can add team members if you want right
now I manage my own account but if you
wanted to add somebody else you can you
can use your own shortener if you want
different analytics on the links that go
out and again you have an overview here
so I have seven tweets currently my
buffer and I've sent almost 500 from my
buffer so I like to use my buffer then
if I continue on I can look at analytics
as an example so if I go back to my
buffer
it doesn't only show you all the ones
that are pending you can click on
analytics and what it'll show you is how
many times each one has been viewed
retweeted clicked on if there's a link
so it gives you detailed analytics for
all the tweets that you send out but
there has to be through the buffer
system and for the account this is free
so what it does is it gives you 10 free
tweets to go out so soon as you use up
those 10 that's kind of your maximum if
you find you tweeting very often you can
either increase the space that when they
go out so I'm only doing you know six a
day you could boost that up if you
wanted to or you can also upgrade your
couch so right now I'm just on the free
account because I find that that's
enough for me but you can click on your
plan here upgrade and you can see that
for 10 bucks or 100 bucks there's
different options so the main benefits
of upgrading if you wanted to were to be
able to post more some 50 post vs 10
posts and to add more accounts so here
you can only have one Twitter account
where you can have multiple on the other
ones if you want but I use the free
version I find that it's enough for me
and hopefully you guys can start testing
it out and using it and improving your
Twitter efficiency and effectiveness as
well so I hope you guys liked it like
this video find it useful if you did I'd
love to hear thoughts of feedback if you
want to leave a comment below your
comments are what really drive all the
new videos that I create so really
appreciate them a pay attention to them
going to try to respond so please leave
a comment below please give it a thumbs
up and if you have any questions as well
let me know and create new videos so
hope to see you soon on the next episode
you